hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
round five of our coverage of the 2018
tata steel tournament our competitors
today whites gonna be played by Shakya
de mama DVF he's had one win in three
draws so pretty good tournament so far
sitting near the top of the leaderboard
a win would put him in a tie for first
place his opponent today playing the
black pieces
Fabiana Caruana he has one loss and
three drawls not quite the tournament he
was hoping for would like to get back on
track with a win here get him back into
contention so we get started from white
starts out with pawn to d4 Knight to f6
upon c4 paani 6:00 at night f3 and then
pawn down to d5 so getting into the
Queen's game a decline line something
that we used to see a ton of haven't
seen as much of it but good to see it
back in format top-level play Bishop
comes up here to a g5 and now Bishop
down here to be for the most common
response for white would be to play
Knight to c3 but we see white in this
position decide to play Knight to d2
instead pawn takes here on c4 pawn to e3
both solidifying the pawn chain also
opening up for this light square bishop
to attack this square and also if he
wants to castle on the kingside des need
to open up the door for the bishop you
get involved you could decide Sofia and
keto on the King side but not really
needing to do that needs to add pressure
to the square here on c4 Fabiano is up a
ponte material but it's very difficult
to hold onto that material he does have
a last-ditch effort here playing pawn to
b5 to try to hold on to as long as
possible
Bishop rarity - getting ready to Castle
Bishop to b7 just being kiddo - the
Queen's had the board Fabiano attacking
this Knights and really just the Kings
side right now
so castle on the King side cast on the
King side and then pawn to b3 Fabiano
does have some options here he took over
16 minutes to figure out how he wanted
to continue the the two main lines that
he has one would be to push forward pawn
to c3
attack this Knight put all white in a
tough position or to take right here if
he takes here on b3 then the Queen could
recapture attack
the bishop behind that the bishop moves
could take this pawn just gonna get that
material back so you could see an
exchange Bishop takes here on D to
Knight recaptures still attacking this
pawn right here how do you really hold
on to it could bring how the Queen up
here you do have both the Queen and the
bishop both eyeing down this pawn right
here if there is an exchange with this
knight there's gonna be double ponts
that's not gonna be as good for black
right here but you see you can see the
Queen's come off the board
maybe the knight takes and then the
bishop comes up here at the end of the
day not a situation that really either
side wanted to go down Fabiana decided
that's not the path he wanted to choose
so instead he decide to play pawn to c3
now and instead of just moving his
knight right away Shakya decided to go
ahead and play pawn to a3 and says yeah
if you want to take my knight that's
fine I'll take your Bishop I'll have the
bishop pair that that's a good trade for
me Bobby I'm not looking to do that
brings his boos you back here to e7 also
wants to support this night here on f6
so now's a good time to go ahead and
bring the knight back here to b1
attacking this pawn this pawn on a3 also
stops the pond coming down here to be
for supporting this pond making it that
much easier for the night to come up to
c3 which is a common development move
you usually see it at the first move not
the third move from the Knights but all
in all will eventually lead to the
square the shack here wants to get to
pawn down to c5 Knight takes on c3 as we
talked about and then pawns hue a6 with
the night here
attacking the square here on b5 wants to
add support does not want to have to use
his pieces to support his pawns now when
you see an exchange after the Bishop
takes Queen up here to see to White has
completed his development from black
side as you can see really the only
piece that he hasn't gotten involved
into the game quite yet is that the
knight to brings his Knight down to d7
and then of rook to d1 this is where
things get a little bit interesting to
me
rook to d1 spells very clearly to the
opponent that you are trying to pin down
this night this night is defending the
square here on f6 and so at the bishop
takes that the knight can just recapture
but it can't move because the
is behind that so this tells me that
that black should have a few options
this is not one is his queen
you know being pinned down and so you
see you could see Queen to b6 this gets
the Queen out of any threats it also
doubles up with the the stars for a
bishop I think that's great move for
black or even if you just want to say
I'm not gonna worry about that let's
just play Bishop back here to e7 so I
don't if you want to come up here and
take that's fine but if you take my
knight I don't want to double up my
pawns here on that file Fabiana took a
different approach
which i think is a little bit odd and he
played rook to c8 always want to get
your rooks involved into the center of
the game especially these open files but
I do think he had some better options
here in this position I thought Shakir
would just go ahead and snap off tanked
Bishop takes on on f6 this is what he
was going for he did take quite some
time to figure out make sure he didn't
miss over anything because it was a
little odd that Fabio don't play to
Brooke to c8 but they at the end of the
day he did decide to go ahead and take
with the bishop here on f6 giving his
opponent a bishop pair knowing that he's
gonna have a much better pawn structure
getting into the endgame
so the pawn recaptures here on f6 pawn
to b4 forcing the bishop to move but she
comes back here to e7 you can see black
really playing defensive mode here where
White's just trying to be as aggressive
as possible get his pieces in the best
positions possible and that's what he
continues to do rook to c1 getting into
an open file here Queens Hui 8 does not
want any material being pinned down on
the D file Queen to be won opening up
the door for his rook to attack now I
can move his knight really control these
long files and the knight to b6 if we
could look from blacks perspective where
does he really go from here it's
LightSquared bishop it's controlling
this long diagonal doesn't make a lot of
sense to bring it back here to eight
that's not really doing anything at
least this adds some value to a backward
pawn here on a6 then I could come to e5
that's one option
I could play King to h8 then bring your
rook to GA try to control the semi-open
file see if you can have an attack on
your opponent you do have your light
square bishop here so this does put some
pressure on your opponent they can't
move there
ship because the pond can't recapture
because that would be an either legal
move if the rooks here on g8 so he has
that option also Fabiana could play pawn
to f5 this does add a little bit
pressure to the center or light squares
he does have the pawn here on e6
controlling the center these light
squares he has the light square Bishop
this pawn might help as well he decides
to go with the knight to b6 and the
knight to a d4 from White's King over
here to h8 as one of the moves to talk
about that we could seen before Bishop
to f3 says I'm not too interested in you
trying to have your rook over here on g8
and then your Bishop all eyeing down
this square here on t2 something to go
ahead and bring my bishop here we do see
an exchange on board so now White has a
better pawn structure and black no
longer has that Bishop here so all in
all I think white definitely has the
upper hand in this game black plays
Knight down here to c4 it is an outpost
it's not really the best outpost of all
time but it is a pretty safe square for
this Knight right now for White Knight
comes up here to e4 starting to attack
his opponent Queen down to c6 forcing
white to respond he plays Knight down
here to d2 he did have his queen
protecting it as well but decides to
bring his knight down here to d2
attacking this Knight Queen back to b7
and the knight takes on c4 and after we
see some exchange on board I think at
the end of the day this works even in
more favor for white because black now
has four pawn structures three isolated
pawn structures you know black is gonna
have to spend a ton of his time and
energy having his major and minor pieces
his Queen Bishop and rook defending his
pawns were White's pawn structures very
solid he can use his own pawns to
protect them and he has free reign with
his Queen rook here a knight here too to
just attack his opponent so although I
think White's gonna have a much better
in game Fabiana is gonna have to figure
something out to get out of this mess
Queens who see two attacking the pawn
over here to see a to protect that pond
up here to h3 just don't want to have to
worry about any sort of back rank make
we're ranked mates for your opponent
comes to this back rank and your King
can't move so this does give him a out
for his King to ever come to h2 if it
needs to Queen down here to c6 just
doubling up on this c4 square white says
yeah I can play that game too rook up
here to d4 pawn to a5 that's fine Knight
down here to d2 and there's too much
pressure on the square and c4 because
it's light square the dark square bishop
from black cannot protect in this game
but this night obviously Canada can move
all over the board and protect any
square it needs to so the rook decides
swing over here to g8 wasn't doing
anything on c8 not add the protection
that he wanted to pawn to g3 there was a
mating opportunity clearly why it's not
going to fall for that but do you want
to always be aware what your opponent's
trying to do it could be very very easy
to just go ahead and take this pawn
right here because it's a free pawn but
then white would end up losing the game
so fabio trying everything he can but
the end of day he is playing one of the
strongest players in the world pawn
takes on before rook takes here says I
can take this pawn back any time I want
to but right now I'm gonna go ahead and
take this pawn and attack the queen pawn
down here and says yeah you can take my
queen I'll take your queen and I'll have
a passed pawn here on c2 why it says
yeah I'll just go ahead and gobble up
thanks for that free material with my
knight here Queen down here to f3 really
black has the option of a perpetual
check trying to have his opponents make
a mistake if the Queen moves maybe can
come down here to d1 he would even
sacrifice his rook if it meant that he
could have a perpetual check just
meaning check check check there's no way
that y can get out of that so white does
have to be aware of that on the board
decided to go and play pawn to a4
doesn't have to worry about the Queen
coming down right here to d1 he has that
protected with his queen on c2 he has a
past pot it's gonna be very difficult
for black to hold on to the Queen side
of the board cuz he has to worry about
everything going on the King side of the
board Bishop to DS
six rook up here to c8 and says let's go
in exchange would you see an exchange
and then we're off to the races anytime
you have a passed pawn you got to get
your material in gear and then you just
gotta push that pass pawn all day long
but you appear to be for trying to stop
the pawn queen up here to see for
attacking the bishop queen up here b7
blacks trying everything you can to hold
on to this material but pawn to e5 you
can see the knight does really well on
one side of the board if there's just
one pawn structure like we have them on
the King side of the board a knight is
preferred over a bishop because it can
just maneuver and control one whole side
Bishop does better controlling two sides
of the board because they can just move
from one side the board to the other
very easily but right here white just
cares about this Queen side much better
for white to have this night here on b3
so the bishop comes back here to d6 and
just continue to push has support right
now from this Queen later on he can get
his knight involved into the game queen
up here to b6
Knight here to d4 Queen down to a5 King
up here to g2 Queen down to a3 just
maneuvering a little bit white can now
see S King safety now maneuver is Queen
to c6 and this allows him to start
pushing forward he can bring his knight
here to b5 attacking the Queen and the
bishop blacks in a really tough spot
here in this position Fabiano decided to
go ahead and resign he did not say any
see any way that he could come out of
this it is a very very easy in game for
grandmasters at this level to get this
pawn promote it and then end up winning
the game Fabiano excited just wasn't
playing the game he was hoping for and
so took his loss not the tournament he
was looking for with two losses now and
three drawls congratulations to Shaq
here he played a fantastic game beating
the number two player in the world
pretty convincingly I never thought that
he was in a position where he didn't
have the upper hand Fabiano did not seem
very comfortable in the lines he was
going down so thing of the day
two wins in three draws he's tied at the
top with the leader so my guess is this
is not the last we will see from him we
do have quite a few rounds left there's
12 rounds in this tournament but thank
you guys for tuning in it's a round
number five and until next time I'll see
you guys the next video